so I thought that I would do some super
aggressive super Blitz this tournament
already began about 8 minutes ago so I
will be late joining but before I join I
want to define the style I'll be playing
in cuz when I say super
aggressive I want to make a few bullet
points of what that actually means yeah
so I mean some of this might end up
going against typical
principles but this won't be kind of the
traditional classical chess of trying to
play objectively good this will be
trying to win quickly trying to just go
straight for the kill so with these
points in mind let's join the
tournament okay o let me make the board
bigger and yeah I might be berserking
against some lower rated players
uh okay going for the early flank Pawn
push inspired by chess
weeb and I still got to develop before I
can attack although okay develop and
attack it's already looking pretty nice
threatening
mate uh let's go for F4 just trying to
open the
position I did leave the D Pawn hanging
momentarily there opponent pushing back
a little
bit yeah let's just try and grab space
if Knight D5 I'll take and then play
F5 so nice aggressive start to the
stream let's
develop oh the knight's coming to F5
though
[Music]
uh that's okay I'll eventually play play
Knight
G3 yeah Knight
G3 oops did I just
blunder wow Knight B4 good
move uh
well that this is not a great start I
just sack a
queen I mean I either have to play this
or this and get forked yeah let's sack a
queen
oh dear I might regret this but at least
I have a more aggressive position good
evening I'm
alive I'm I'm alive too but
barely uh
check if King here I take with check
King here I take with
check okay here I take with check as
well I have 30 seconds left what the
starts of the tournament and to the
stream
check
check okay I'll take a bishop it's kind
of working out I'm threatening Maiden
two check and mate the triple Fork
mate okay I don't need a queen at least
in some cases
wow that was uh definitely not a clean
game but maybe that's a preview of what
we can expect for the games to
come okay we go again I'll berserk I'll
play G5 this is uh some sort of Gambit
although White's not accepting it so
I'll kick around the
Knight already some initia O Okay
opponent being aggressive too sacking
the Knight to expose my king but
uh okay I'm I'm used to pushing the
fling Pawns
let's what do I want to
do I should probably develop let's offer
the trade maybe get the Knight into play
and then try and get the f file for The
Rook get the other Knight
[Music]
in yeah if F4 I can on
assant okay well now we have an opposite
side kind of opposite I castling except
I didn't really Castle the King has
found its way to the king
side oh if I take then the G file opens
so I think I'm better off playing C5
here kicking the queen so the Knight
will not be pinned now I win the
bishop and now we're in
business Bishop E6 defending the tack
will hopefully come
[Music]
soon
um
bad oh no my
Bishop why could take the bishop and I
take the
Knight I don't really want to trade
Queens
though but I might have
to yeah I think I have
to okay a rare retreating move if white
trades Queens I'll still have some
potential
attack uh here let's move
over yeah the aggression won't stop even
though Queens are off the board 33
seconds
here maybe Rook AC is actually Rook yeah
Rook HCA to preserve A5 and
A4
going for some double
up it's almost meing
now might as well take the
[Music]
Knight okay I'm trying to create a
mating that with uh the minor pieces in
The Rook getting closer this is just use
my king as
[Music]
well like this and this would be
checkmates to control
E4 okay got the mate 16 seconds to spare
moving
on so couple berserk
wins welcome back Queen G E3
mate thank you earlier here to I will
Rook you up and PM
forer couple Prime
Subs okay playing
neocon uh I'll berserk again and I'll
play E4 let's play a tennis and
gabit going for the intercontinental
ballistic missile
whatever um although yeah Black's not
going into it but we still have some
Gambit type
position
uh let's develop get castled
quickly O
Okay that was a nice
gift when the
queen I'm still trying to go for the
attack get rid of this
Knight take a
pawn and
let's how to do
this maybe the bishop can reroute to
C3 now I'm going
in I don't think I'm turning Force M
okay well this is made in one okay uh
nice quick game there I that may have
been the quickest game so far I'm
joining join the game what wait what oh
maybe it didn't register I won that game
because it was kind of
quick okay so I'm fourth place after
three
games leader has four berserk wins I'm
trying to catch
up again for those just joining I have a
little oops I minimized
everything did I do I have a little
bullet point list of some style points
to stick
to going to try and go for a
Stafford if I can't play a Stafford then
yeah the aggressive way to play this
position is I guess here I can play
Bishop G4 and then go for Knight
D4 if G4 I'll I'll sack for
sure okay opponent's not letting
me play My Knight D4
move so let's go for Rook g8s preparing
G5 yeah I didn't want to suffer with
triple
pawns okay now yeah now I'll sack it
might be questionable but it might be
hard for white to resolve the
pin and something
like maybe Queen F6
first king and queen are tied
down
reinforce the
bishop
interesting I take the Rook let's attack
The Rook I'm not going to take it right
away Rook here then I play
H4 I'll take with
[Music]
Chuck okay another opposite side cting
type position White's trying to attack
as well but I'm also Pawn
storming if this I can play this if this
I'll play
this I still have all eight
pawns somehow my a pawn moved to the C
file but really it was just a capture
and a
capture all right I'm trying to open
vils
uh do I let White
Queen no that's too much let's play this
move I could have played King B7 too
probably but I feel like the king is a
bit safer
here and now I can focus on the
attack F files
open maybe G3 or H3 coming maybe
both
okay attacking this maybe preparing
this yeah this Pawn is guaranteed to
Queen that's a free
rook okay dude I got lip balm for
Christmas haha or
quack that's a probably a nice practical
gift thanks for the great
content oh thank you yeah so this
started as like a very symmetrical
opening but quickly got crazy there hi
Eric what are some of your goals in life
outside of
Chess um probably
happiness maybe eventually world
domination but we'll start with
happiness ah crispy lips got lip balm
yeah lip balm is a
bomb especially when you have crispy
lips also thank you ruckle thank you
Mark fooy all right let's play um
whatever this
is Danish Scotch verasa no not FIS off
Goring
gambits okay opponent uh is kind of
declining the gambits I'll play this
move still trying to prioritize
initiative and attack if takes takes
takes I play Rook
E1 I'll harass the
queen
yeah if F6 I can take and prepare Rook e
one now I'm going to kick the queen
around going for Knight C4
to I mean this is trapping the queen
because Queen here here I have Knight
D6 black does get a minor piece for
it
okay this is mate okay that was a nice
game a Gambit paid off gained her rating
points in second place trailing this
person thank you py Bok happy 40
months yeah I don't think that was a the
real
alza although maybe it's just someone
else named
alza all right playing E4
here what other Gambit to play Let's
play the hillbilly
it's a Gambit I haven't played in a
while against the
kocan if that takes I'll play Queen H5
if
that's
of what do I want to
[Music]
do actually don't know what to do here
Knight C3 maybe just accelerate
development if this I can reroute and
try and get some kingside
attack um
D3 if takes I don't think I'll take back
I'll play Bishop G5 and I'll just
prioritize development like if takes I
play KN
F3 not something to try at home
especially if you're a young
child uh what to do here maybe I haven't
been able to watch in a while hope
everything is going well oh welcome back
resilience yeah things are going well
long time no see hope you're doing
well this is the most aggressive move I
could think of there attacking two
pawns and I I could take but let's uh
let's just marinate the pawn before
consuming
it and maybe the plan is to play H4 and
Knight
G5 actually Knight G5 is a pretty big
threat to attack these
things because I already have two
attackers against
F7
that's not super comfortable for that
like G6 I can then take actually G6
maybe Queen H6 even more
aggressive I'm through to the final 151
players left in the 68th chess.com
tournament thanks for all the
instructive chess keep it up helps I
like your name I like your your verbs
and your nouns and
yeah keep it up and happy six
months okay so I'm cashing in a little
bit win a Pawn on E6 and I think I still
want to play Knight G5 like I don't want
to take my foot off the
gas start with
this if Knight F6 I'll play Bishop
F5 just trying to creep into this h s
Square I mean the combination of this
and this and there's going to be
multiple threats it's a double birthday
I am turning five and also
39 hey C Greco welcome back happy 60
months it's today your birthday
too wait 60 months is 5
years wow yeah happy
birthday I don't want to trade Queens
but getting low on time let's
Castle I have to play aggressively to
win this with 21 seconds
left uh giving this Pawn
though okay I had to
defend going for the attack
still yeah G5 is looming
welcome back to Yuri Yuri in the house
appreciate the raid if you're just
joining I'm trying to play the most
aggressive chest
possible uh but I don't have much time
here 17
seconds go for aggression on the
[Music]
seventh got to use my king
now Rook C7 I probably should have
played
first hi Eric I was just watching you on
you YouTube LOL oh
LOL
nice uh oh
I can pre moove on the light
squares okay just quick enough
there H got to the end
game first place let's go 28 minutes
left the aggression will hopefully not
stop shout out to Yuri who is uh oh you
have the girlfriend over okay yeah
better to probably give her more
attention than
me um thanks
again have a good night pleas
another E4
game I'll try and mix up the types of
gambits too like if another kocan
happens I do have another Gambit in mind
okay here we'll play A Smith
Mora o Knight
F6 play
E5 don't think I've seen this one before
and it looks good for white
already black wants to win this
Pawn I play Bishop
B5 obstructing the queen A6 I can
take so I Zed up PA but I have a nice
lead in
development probably ready to Castle and
then ideally Knight D5 Knight C7
eventually a lot of attacking ideas H3
also on
tap and not the easiest position for
black ooh G5 wow I could take it but
just save the
pawn now H3 if H4 I take and pin the H
Pawn if this I probably
take now threatening
this save the
bishop just defending
everything A3 may be
coming wow opponent's also trying to
play really
aggressively and let's make a
threat Queen here B4 I did weaken B3 but
I'm kicking the queen around Queen here
I have Knight D5 takes Knight
[Music]
C7 if Queen C7 maybe E6 to
unleash was a funl looking
position Queen doesn't have too many
options Knight B3 I can take and then
take
take yeah oh no my
Bishop now can I play
E6 threatening Maiden
one and also unleashing this bishop to
support Knight C7 to win the
queen so if Knight takes I take and then
take and then yeah also this Pawn is
pinned on
[Music]
D7
so things are coming together not scared
of the
fork oh that pawn could take and the
King can run I'll still win The Rook or
queen yeah and I'll still try and keep
the momentum going like E5 I can take
Knight Will hopefully come
back Bishop can
[Music]
attack attack the
knights attack the
king okay
attack the rook and the
Knight
up on
time life is good I'll take the Knight
first I can't take the Rook cuz Queen
D2 very
tricky
never too late to
[Music]
Castle okay that's a free
Queen okay that was a fun game a fun
position from the opening there so
trying to extend the
lead ooh I recognize this name maybe a
subscriber we've played a few times
before
uh let's play a new opening we'll play a
scandy ed5 was pre moved very
nice yeah playing some scandy Gambit
which
opponent is not taking so might as well
take and assuming White Castle's King
side yeah I'll aim to Castle Queen side
we'll go for a Sharp position maybe KN a
four
I can't do that just yet go for H6 and
G5 still trying to get in
G5 cuz yeah Bishop G3 is a bit more
difficult to play that's a complicated
move we'll take first
then
[Music]
taken now What's Happening
Here
G5 I want to play F6 but then there's
Knight
G6 which is a little bit
annoying
okay but now F6 is likely
[Music]
coming and even though there's been a
lot of Trades there's still attacking
potential if I can get in like Rook G8
and G4 and maybe H5
included kick the Knight
away opening the G
file we are basically in the end game
though but with Queens on the board half
open G
file still still some potential to
attack I guess I'm allowing a rook
trade
um play this first oh that was a really
bad move forgot the thing was defending
the thing yeah the queen was defending
the
Rook well now I'm down a pawn and down a
minute and it's going to be hard to play
aggressively
here like my attack just didn't work at
[Music]
all now white can force a queen
trade but I'm still being aggressive
working some
pawns winning back upon PA Rook E7 King
B6 and now the plans to push a
pawn
[Music]
yeah this is very
useful
oh
no that was a bad pre
moove okay just in
time oh that was a really bad pre move I
was expecting this and then just
blockading but then the king moved
here okay made that work
out still staying clean berserking all
the
games 19 minutes
left I have time for a handful
more I think this is my first sip of tea
this stream I've been so focused on
chess forgot about my tea but it's tea
time the mug doesn't lie
okay playing Warrior 2000 Let's uh play
another E4 berserking again maybe I can
play like an Evans
[Music]
or uh what to do
here let's play D4 this is one
aggressive approach oh maybe I'll play a
naanson if takes here here and then
Knight
C3 shout out to Jonathan
sh I mean there was the whole nmon craze
few years
[Music]
ago uh okay here I can play Knight G oh
Knight G5 there's this move
though but then this move and then this
wait a minute
this can I play this
move take
take it's Highly Questionable but I'll
go for it so takes takes takes takes
is like the most aggressive
approach I'm down upon PA here but I
have way more
development a lot of pressure against
the
Knight can't really stop the
trade I just want to get the knight
in thank you mangor be aggressive be
aggressive
save
amen actually uh that's Mingo RK yeah
sorry for uh mispronouncing your name
for so
long okay can I take a
bishop let's uh yeah let's use a knight
to exert
pressure oh it's ATC fost yeah don't be
sorry it's part of the tournament and
competition um there's there's been
times where I don't berserk opponents
back like various title
[Music]
Arenas um I take the
bishop how to be aggressive here it's
not
easy I'll play Queen
F3 I'm trying to make a gun of some
sort maybe Queen g3 at some
point oh okay we have opposite side
castling this makes me
happy now I have a clear plan even
though the king is pretty safe here for
the time being it's time to push a flank
Pawn if Bishop here I think I can take
and win
material okay see3 trying to open up
files I did open up this which I guess I
have to deal with
now oh this is not
[Music]
good
uhoh oh this is really
[Music]
bad hi Eric I love the rapid speedrun
series I'm in trouble
oh I love your
words if only love could save me from
this
[Music]
position Rook F2
maybe oh good
move now I'm the victim of
[Music]
aggression
uhoh oh okay
it finally backfired not the proudest
finish there there goes my streak let's
uh okay let's try and keep some
aggression going I'll play a different
aggressive opening the OS solivan Gambit
which I did make a video on way back
when I Gambit the B Pawn to try and
exploit uh this bishop if takes I win
back the thing I think
Queen takes as
[Music]
playable
so yeah I'm still down a pawn but this
will come with
[Music]
Tempo ooh what's happening
here wow I can't take cuz I lose a queen
but I think I can play
this
Queen F4 have this move or this
move yeah white is trying to give me a
taste of my own
medicine indeed indeed how's it going
zcat it's uh yeah I think this is
manageable at this point I just want to
not get
mated and then start attacking attacking
a pawn to untangle
here yeah so let's get this bishop in
play and maybe I'll have I mean I'll
have some
nice Bishops aimed at White's King
side start with
this G3 this that will over defend E6 so
I can play
this oh no my
bishop and okay so the knight's pinned
to G2 question is what is my plan going
forward why wants to play
this but white first probably wants to
unpin so if this
then I take if Queen takes I
check King here I
mate I mean white has other options like
this
move and this is the only move
actually
and I'm still trying to attack of the
extra
Knight down a little bit of time and the
goal now is to push the H Pawn trying to
open the H file if Rook E1 I'll defend
with Rook
H6 that made oh oh no my
knight
uhoh I just give this away I have to
play
this way have
Perpetual oh
[Music]
no
this is not
good if I play this there's this this I
just get M it I think to play
this we off one's
coming
I have 12 seconds left is white going to
take a
draw draw is
[Music]
possible okay now I'm playing for a
win
there we go winning the
queen
okay oh that took some trickery oo suai
is trying to catch up
neither of us are on a streak though we
might play each
other yeah playing Soul tie long time no
see double berserk I'll try and play
aggressively we'll play oh I meant to
play B4 we'll play a delayed Wing Gambit
how
about uh let's
take and what does this
take Bishop
B2 Happy New Year year year to see the
streams are pretty regular to start the
year yeah it's been a
pleasure okay here I have to follow some
principles still trying to get
initiative early
though ring C5
maybe thanks for that PO neck
I do want to create some attack on the
king
side it might be sacking actually let's
save The
Rook it's honestly not the most
aggressive game so
[Music]
far yeah okay now I'm
sacking is V going to take the Rook
though
doesn't take
it but takes the pawn probably a good
move play
D5 let's go for Bishop
A1 D4
[Music]
idea okay so I lost my D
Pawn I do want to open the DI
allowing this
[Music]
move not the greatest
position okay got some help
there
[Music]
up a lot of
time we're both trying to attack on the
king's
side
okay slightly dirty finish thank you
aruka gifting five reasonable with a
prime do appreciate
it yeah I I did get out played that game
never really got any attack
going um but managed to stay alive and
Prevail in the time of
scramble so there's 6 minutes left
that's time for probably at least two
more
games lost one game so far okay now I'll
actually play a wing Gambit
well I intended to play the last
game go for
this um
B5 maybe D5
coming
Knight
H6 okay so trying to focus on Center
play I mean let's uh let's violate some
principle
here oh I'm still
pinned take wow that's a good
move I'm going to go for this I'll sack
the G pawn and then try and use the G
file
and I maybe have accidentally trapped
the Knight cuz now yeah it can't access
F4 H4 is
defended so I think that worked out
nicely go for E5
now if Queen E6 I can take
probably
okay going for the
attack G6 Knight
E4 Knight is trying to come
in yeah I'm really just trying to throw
the kitchen sink at box King
side um F5 is resourceful
though take
so
pinning yeah black was trying some
Discovery but maybe didn't realize I
take with
Chuck now it's looking very
good
okay this game will definitely count for
the tournament black has one legal
move I guess it's a question if I'll get
another game in
though okay back to
tournament yeah maybe time for one more
game to count no guarantee though have
to win in less than three minutes
I haven't gotten a Stafford yet okay
here maybe I go for Budapest maybe I'll
go for whatever this like wagon is it
called the
wagon Jonathan tr's creation A6 and then
E5 trying to finish with a grand
finale of I don't know what this okay
let's play E5 anyway takes all playing
the
E4 I sacking pawns because they're in
the way of my
pieces Bishop
B4 and this might hurt me
but okay oh oops this is going to hurt
me that was
careless opponent's trying to figure out
why it's
[Music]
poisonous and they I guess they trusted
me or didn't see the Knight was hanging
oh ATC says oh I could have gone for
Stafford yeah that was a scandavian
game okay so what is this position
I'm I'm down a pawn there's this pin I'm
losing another Pawn
maybe go for D
D5 I got to play quickly if I want this
game to count though
oh the knight's no longer pinned yeah
got to
take probably
queen queen
here some potential to lift The
Rook okay now two things are
attacked
undevelop the bishop to hopefully
someday redevelop
it okay I'm trying to use the F5
[Music]
what's my
plan Bishop here Knight
here maybe
this okay tournament's
ending uh so let's just try and win this
game
let that's a okay I guess I have a fork
which took me a long time to see
take not getting
mated and this Knight is being fed too
[Music]
well
okay well that concludes the
tournament uh that was fun I did lose a
game did I lose rating this
tournament hey I broke
even 12 wins one
loss uh good job Soul Tai finishing in
second so I hope people enjoy that um
I've been doing a lot of like more
instructive solid speedrun content
recently but uh yeah it's nice to have a
a super aggressive super Blitz once in a
while
so if this goes on YouTube let me know
what your favorite game was every game
will be
timestamped if you're watching in in the
future on YouTube and you want to watch
live be sure to follow on
Twitch or subscribe on Twitch if you
want to support the
channel twitch chat says
hi twitch chat says ding luren is
playing right
now ding luren is playing right now on
not online but in the tournament China
chess King
2003 hey it's dingler n
okay
uh it's hard to like transition from
what I just
did to watching the current world
champion play like a looks like very
strategic positional
endgame